- You guys paying attention?
- What?
SCOTT LANG
I don't believe you.
CASSIE LANG
Let's just show him.
- Alright.
- Okay.
KATHRYN NEWTON
[Gasps] Oh my God! Oh my gosh!
SCOTT LANG
Wait, you have a suit?
KATHRYN NEWTON
Oop! Sorry.
EVANGELINE LILLY
She was very excited. So cool.
PAUL RUDD
These are really good!
JONATHAN MAJORS
Hey, buddy!
PAUL RUDD
I think they really captured our likenesses.
KATHRYN NEWTON
That looks so much like you, that's crazy!
JONATHAN MAJORS
This is really, really, really cool.
I mean, there he is.
With the hand!
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You're out of your league, Ant-Man.
PAUL RUDD
Let's go!
EVANGELINE LILLY
Yes!
PAUL RUDD
Yeah!
Kaw! Kaw! Kaw! Kaw!
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You thought you could win.
- Iyk!
- Ah!
PAUL RUDD
That's awesome!
SCOTT LANG
Word of advice...
Look out for the little guy.